earlier in my life when I would think
all of these strange things and I love
to cartoon and draw oh I didn't know I
was not a I could I couldn't draw
or I never really tried that hard to
draw realistically or depict something
but lots of cartoons and lots of like I
would draw little silly characters and I
would make cartoons and that's fine
answer your phone
um no I'm I'm clearly I'm a priority you
would think I was shutting it off but I
want to see what this no I said
I shut it off
the call and it was a Spam call when I'm
working with the guy what's involved I
don't know
I don't need blind
hold on wait a minute tell me more and
I'm going on and on about the stew still
um
but what I'm saying is I'm constantly uh
any anyone who's in this business and
and isn't uh realized that
um you know it is a complete
crazy privilege to get to get any money
or rent or mortgage payment any money
that you can make uh in this world I
think I mean Sona you have a really good
perspective on it because you came at
this from this crazy angle and
um and now it's just well I gotta go in
and talk to Steven Wright I know and
it's
I I can't believe it like I I I would
pay to do this I can't believe I'm glad
you said that oh no no no no no no no no
you should pay okay I forget I said you
know no no no no no you're right come on
you know I'm curious like I know I'm
very grateful I also think there's
something about
maybe I'd feel differently if I had
grown up in Los Angeles or grown up
around this but
it's very hard for me to explain to
people how Massachusetts and especially
the era that we grew up in
um 60s 70s coming of age in that time
there was Show Business was further
removed from not just Massachusetts but
Massachusetts Vermont New Hampshire
Rhode Island that area the last thing in
the world you ever thought Could Happen
was that you could it be in Show
Business I saw no evidence that show
business existed I didn't see famous
people I didn't know anybody who was
related you know my dad's a fake
scientist at the bus station like that
you never thought
that that you would get any chance uh
and I think it's a different world now
people people think about things
differently and Boston looks so
different now I mean the look at movies
from the 60s and 70s that depict Boston
look at the verdict look at
um uh friends of Eddie Coyle look at
these movies that show Boston in the
seven it's so gray and it's so
unappealing in so many ways and kind of
depressed so real and so real and kind
of grittiness yeah no slickness at all
and then I remember leaving coming to La
getting involved in other stuff in my
career and then coming back to Boston in
the late 80s
and suddenly there's like panquatidians
everywhere and people were saying would
you like a crepe and I was like this is
not the Boston I grew up in you can go
back and look at those movies and I go
like that's the boss that's it cars that
are rusted out yeah everyone's wearing a
gray jacket policemen are all really
heavy their belts are like around their
nipples and they're directing traffic
but I don't think they've ever shot a
gun in their life nobody's you know
people people aren't that nice it's cold
the snow all turns right away
right away somehow that all changed hey
whether you're stuck in traffic or
streaming your favorite podcasts that's
where I come in it's important to have a
network you can trust wherever you are
say it with me T-Mobile yeah you didn't
really have to say it with me but it is
your network you know I'm excited about
T-Mobile yeah you're killing it and uh
you know I was really excited it's our
good friend blay who's been using this
service blade tell us about it yeah I
have been a T-Mobile a subscriber for a
really long time it they're awesome I
download videos all the time yeah you do
you like you download a lot of videos
yeah now you've never read a book no no
books are overrated but uh and I listen
to this podcast on a hike fantastic up
in the mountains you'd listen to our
podcast I will contract you work here
yeah I have to I have to I have to
listen to it but it's great and and
honestly like the coverage is is insane
uh and yeah I love the service I love
the phone it's fantastic it's experience
for yourself how T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can't
top them I like all the G's you bet you
do find out more at t-mobile.com Cy
that's
s-e-e-w-h-y fastest based on median
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data 4.
Q4 2022 good wow that's incredible yeah
I said exactly what they wanted
5G details at
t-mobile.com it's just like a whole
different vibe yeah and I think that
realness that you just described
makes us appreciate what do you mean you
you're gonna go do this show and that's
how you're gonna pay the rent what do
you mean because all you see is people
doing that's real like you know jobs
that's why I appreciate it
all the time it's like a it's playing
don't you think this is playing oh it's
it's totally playing it's like being in
five or ten and you're finger painting
but with words yeah oh imagine this oh
imagine you know you're in the cafeteria
you're saying to your friend right and
then that's this becomes your career now
what do you prefer obviously you're very
comfortable on a stage you're great on a
stage
do you like being up in front of people
or do you prefer the part where you're
crafting it uh
uh two different things writing them in
cereal and then performing the material
I I the the right the performance is
very intense to me even still now I mean
I'm not nervous but it's like walking a
tightrope
the way I it's like you were running
across a lake of thin ice and you're
trying to get to the other side without
falling through during the length of the
show right that's very intense I would
say that the the writing is more of a
it's enjoyable it has no intensity
you just mind in your own business and
then something happens how do you feel
about being in front of the audience I
can't imagine on television night after
night after night how you know how how
it was so funny because there's a one of
the great comedy writers of all time
George Meyer worked at The Simpsons when
I was there and he's you know legendary
uh brilliant guy and he had worked on
the early Letterman show
and I was being considered as possibly
being one of the people who might
replace Letterman and my name is
starting to show up in the trades and
you know my friend I'm working at The
Simpsons and my friends are like this is
crazy this is insane and when I I know I
don't think it's gonna happen but it's
crazy and they're like man but but
you're a funny guy this could be a funny
show I think you could do it and they're
all saying no no I think you could do it
I remember George Meyer I went out in
the parking lot and George Meyer was
walking with me
it's like oh man I wouldn't do it if I
were to you and I said really and this
didn't come from anything but he was
just being honest and he went I worked
on one of those shows every day feed the
dragon
feed the dragon every day and he was
like don't do it it'll ruin your life
he wasn't wrong but
I'm also was the best thing I ever did
and and what I found was this magical
thing I realized very early on doing an
hour a day I remember the worst thing
about this job is that you have to do it
every day forever the best thing about
this job is that you get to do it every
day for an hour because when you crank
up the volume like that
you start to uh over time
um think
what the hell what the let's give
it a shot that's a you know masturbating
bear let's give it a shot you know uh
dog puppet that insults people and says
you suck
um I want to poop on you let's try it I
don't know how you did it I don't know
how you did that over and over and over
and over uh well my as I said to
somebody once they said Jesus you know
four thousand three hundred something
shows
what's the what's how did you do it and
I said the trick is
some of them aren't very good
that's just kind of true like yeah there
you you look at some and you go oh I see
how he did it that wasn't so good but we
always tried